well Doreen
cool guy everybody's favorite Wolverine
favorite x-man
look I've been going over your file I've
made the decision to fire you because
you are worthless what you're worthless
and your fire fire let's add listening
to your already impressive list of
skills I'll put it right next to I'm
made of metal the substance that the guy
we fight the most can manipulate with
his mind but I've got these yes very
impressive also made of metal but I
guess handy brothers fights where you
can get right next to the person you
need to attack this is your power that's
it you flail I'm pretty important to
this team bub okay let's say magneto is
on one side of a bridge and he's killing
a lot of people like a lot and we arrive
on the other side of the bridge you
gonna run Adam gonna run at Magneto
I'm very fast okay even if you're very
fast still gonna take you quite a while
couple minutes
that's what three dozen people dead or
storm fly over two seconds suck him into
a hurricane into a goddamn hurricane
problem solved I have a motorcycle maybe
I'd ride that what is a motorcycle made
of tubes I'm sorry you say tube glass
and tubes I really feel you picturing a
motorcycle and trying
it's made of mad mad metal metal it's
made of metal which magnetic you can
twist and Bend and throw you off the
bridge now you're in debt I'm very
useful to the team I guess when you're
not off somewhere having harrowing
visions of your origin oh where did I
come from
where did I come
no no you're not hearing me no one gives
a hodge but where did I come from get a
journal Logan you're gonna have to find
gainful employment somewhere else
well I do where do I go I don't really
give a [ __ ] if I had my way you and
Beast would be over the airport sniffing
bags for the TSA it's one of your things
isn't it I can smell really far if that
does not help us you do not help us I
have a motorcycle you're not all here
are you I'm not all there are you just
saying back to me what I am saying did
you repeat what I said well hmm
Wolverine I'm gonna write you a
prescription for an anti-psychotic that
I'd like you to take I have a motor
saying you're fired I'd kill you with my
mind but doesn't feel right feel like
I'd be putting down a special needs
member of the cast of Footloose huh I'm
gonna go fight some nerds hey Wolverine
you want to see my claws hey hey